نبقى في اوكرانيا منعو سقوط اوكرانيا
وصمود جيشها حتى الان امام ثاني اكبر جيوش
العالم اثار استغراب الكثيرين غير ان
الفضل بهذا الصمود يعود لثلاثه قاده
عسكريين يقومون بادوار في ساحات المعارك
لا تقل عن دور زيلينسكي لكنهم كل البعد عن
الاعلام الجنرال الجنرالات الثلاثه الذين
ساهموا في منع سقوط اوكرانيا ينتمون الى
حقبه ما بعد الاتحاد السوفيتي ومسلحين
بثقافه الناتو بحسب تقرير لصحيفه نموض
الفرنسيه هؤلاء القاده المحوريين وفق
الصحيفه الفرنسيه لم يرتكبوا خطا
الاستخفاف بعدوهم وبنفس الوقت لم يبالغوا
بتقدير قوه الجيش الروسي اولهم فاليري
زالوشني القائد الاعلى للقوات الاوكرانيه
الذي يوصف بالرجل الحديدي
[موسيقى]
اما ثاني القاده فهو قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال اوليكسون
بنقل جميع مراكز القياده الى الميدان
باتجاه المحاور المحتمله للتقدم الروسي
قبل نحو اسبوع من بدء العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه كما اصدر امرا بنقل الاصول الجويه
للجيش الاوكراني بما في ذلك المروحيات
والطائرات النفاثه من القواعد الرئيسيه
وذلك ابعدها بشكل كبير عن اهداف الغارات
الجويه الواضحه نظم ايضا حلقتين من القوات
لحمايه كياف احداهما في الضواحي الخارجيه
للعاصمه ومنها داخل العاصمه
[موسيقى]
فيما ثالث الجنرالات الاوكرانيين مشاهدينا
والذي كان بمثابه الدعامه للقوات
الاوكرانيه فهو كاريلو بودان اوف قائد
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه حارب ضد
القوات الروسيه بالوكاله في الحرب التي
اندلعت شرقي اوكرانيا عام 2014 من خلال
مجموعه عمليات خاصه شارك بودانوف في تبادل
الاسرى وشغل منصب رئيس هيئه تنسيق التعامل
مع اسرى الحرب كما كان عضوا في الوفد
الاوكراني بمحادثات انهاء الحصار الروسي
للبحر الاسود
[موسيقى]